هل عجز المعلم عن حمل رسالته وعن نقلها
بين الاجيال بهدوء جدل يحدثه معلم
الكيمياء بعد تسريب مقطع فيديو له وهو
يهين طالباته في احد المعاهد الخاصه التي
يعمل بها في بغداد
محاضره اليوم
حسني والذي عرف بين طلابه بادائه العلمي
المتميز يحال الى مجلس تحقيقي من قبل
وزاره التربيه العراقيه وبمهله 48 ساعه
للكشف عن اسباب تصرفه المخالف تماما لصفته
المهنيه كتربوي اولا ومن ثم كمعلم
غسب منير
وين المتابعون ان الطالبات هن من اخرجنا
المعلمه عن شعوره بينما يجد اخرون ان هذا
السلوك هو السلوك المعتاد لهذا المعلم
ولاخرين غيره فمن امن العقاب اساء الادب
كما علق رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
الذين اتفقوا على ان المعاهد الخاصه باتت
بؤره خطره على طلاب والطالبات لما فيها من
مخالفات مسكوت عنها زينب المشاط صباح
العربيه بغداد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات